we begin this morning with the questions
over what sparked a deadly shooting at a
Florida Navy base on Friday morning four
people including the gunman were killed
and eight others were injured during the
attack at a Naval Air Station in
Pensacola CBS News has learned the
gunman was muhammad sayyid al sham rani
and he was a Saudi Arabian national and
a pilot in training for the Saudi Air
Force he had been training in the United
States since 2017 the FBI is
investigating al sham Ronnie's social
media posts and whether he acted alone
but investigators have not said what his
possible motive might have been this
morning we're learning more about one of
the victims David beg know is in
Pensacola David good morning good
morning you know the military usually
waits about 24 hours to notify the next
of kin in a situation like this where
someone has died but we were able to
overnight confirm the identity of one of
the victims CBS News has learned that
Joshua caleb watson was one of the three
people killed by muhammad sayyid al sham
Ronnie on Friday the 23 year old Watson
graduated this year from the Naval
Academy he was from Alabama and as a
student he made the Dean's List he was
also captain of the rifle team in a
Facebook post his brother said that
Watson's final act saved countless lives
writing after being shot multiple times
he made it outside and he told the first
response team where the shooter was and
those details were invaluable he died a
hero
this sprawling naval base was locked
down after al-sham rani stormed a
classroom and opened fire with a handgun
within minutes authorities charged into
the building to Escambia County
sheriff's deputies shot and killed
al-sham Rani but were wounded in the
process both deputies are expected to
survive
they ran to the fight not from the fight
and even though they knew there was an
active shooter and again the chances of
putting your life in danger are great
guess where they went they went inside
this morning the FBI is trying to
determine how a foreign national
obtained a handgun which is prohibited
by law and brought it onto the base
according to the Middle East Media
Research Institute someone matching
al-sham Ronnie's identity had an
extensive online footprint in a Twitter
post the writer says Oh American people
I hate you
because everyday you supporting funding
and committing crimes not only against
Muslims but also humanity as of this
morning federal officials are not saying
what happened here was an act of terror
we are not prepared at this hour to
confirm what may have motivated the
shooter to commit this horrific act
today investigators are looking for any
signs of radicalization going back to al
sham Ronnie's upbringing in Saudi Arabia
King Salman of Saudi Arabia called
President Trump after the shooting the
king said that the Saudi people are
greatly angered by the barbaric actions
of the shooter and that this person in
no way shape or form represents the
feelings of the Saudi people who loved
the American people al sham Rani was one
of a few hundred foreign nationals who
trained here at the Naval Air Station
last night the defense secretary mark
espera said he's going to take a look at
the vetting procedures that go into
accepting foreign nationals to be able
to train here you know the FBI called a
news conference last night at about
eight o'clock we weren't sure if we were
gonna get some important details we
really didn't at all you got the sense
that this is a very fluid situation they
said a lot of resources are being flown
in Jeff I would expect that later today
based on what we were told last night we
should find out the identity of the
other two victims killed
all right David thank you very much